and of course i am happy about the
election result that the citizens of
the place which has been for
weeks this is going
to be a long election evening this is
want dear
people shifted into the red managers world
for africa the one the changing the end
and day wanted uwe olaf scholz es  the
next chance on the country we are
a pragmatic party the
static
as well as batch of utah in germany
is want to cover the country in the iss
unity support from everybody on stage
trio or
magnetism confidence in criticism the g
and competent sharing unity that is
motto the future is important and the
city wants
the spd
[applause]
now we are also waiting for the final
election result but also breaking the
fine result in the blick
[applause]